[Musique]
chaque semaine on entend parler d'une
cyberattaque quelque part dans le monde
il y a deux semaines par exemple les
etats-unis ont annoncé que leurs réseaux
électriques et nord américain a été la
cible d'une intrusion par des pirates
informatiques
d'ailleurs washington croit que saviez
de la russie des pirates informatiques
sont aujourd'hui capables de provoquer
des pannes majeures
c'est une menace bien réelle et qui
résonne jusque ici au canada
nous sommes allés à la rencontre de ceux
qui combattent ces attaques pour la
deuxième fois en moins de deux mois une
cyberattaque majeure à paralyser des
entreprises et des services publics dans
les chats sans toi
c'est vraiment une cyber ans sont ya
bien été organisée où ils vendent leurs
produits et la propagation du virus a eu
lieu en quelques heures son nom petya
il s'appelle pétillât aux blacks
l'ukraine est une habituée des
cyberattaques en décembre 2015
une panne électrique suspecte plonge une
partie du pays dans le noir
225 mille foyers sont privés de courant
le matin tu étais vraiment coordonnées
aucun doute là dessus le coupable un
logiciel malveillant incrusté dans des
ordinateurs névralgique du réseau pro
compagnie d'énergie électrique en
ukraine qui ont été attaqués en même
temps une attaque n'attend pas l'ombre
un an plus tard le réseau électrique
ukrainien est une fois de plus pris
d'assaut par les pirates
cette fois ci c'est avec un nouveau le
shell malveillants que personne n'avait
jamais vu dans le passé qu'ils étaient
des années spécialement pour s'attaquer
aux systèmes de contrôle industriels au
niveau du des réseaux électriques
les virus et logiciels malveillants se
succèdent au rythme des cibles qu'ils
visent ils menacent maintenant nos
infrastructures les plus essentiels et
personne n'est à l'abri pas même hydro
québec et pour une compagnie qui se
pense capable de dire que risque 0226
banque inclusion
oh non c'est alexis d'argent qu'un jeu
directeur bureau de recherche et
développement dix sept bases à montréal
i7 est une firme de cyber sécurité qui
traque les logiciels malveillants
des chercheurs de l'entreprise en europe
ont détecté le logiciel malveillant l
origine de la tacc de 2016 en ukraine
c'est un logiciel qui cache une son
système et qui permet quelques uns en
prendre le contrôle à distance et c'est
à baptiser le logiciel industrial and
fire est spécifique a été codé
spécifiquement pour attaquer des
systèmes de contrôle industriel ce qu'il
faut savoir ce qu'elle attaque était
préprogrammés davance l'intérêt des
cyberpirates pour les infrastructures
prend de l'ampleur
les attaques à distance devienne une
réalité
déjà il ya une
hamdane et le
gouvernement américain en avait fait la
démonstration lors de tests sur une
génératrice au diesel
la cyberattaque contrôler avait
lourdement endommagé l'équipement la
quantité d'équipement qui pourraient
être visés par une soirée et est
extrêmement vaste et définitivement pas
juste en ukraine ou en europe de l'est
en ukraine je pense que c'était un
signal clair de lune si on a suivi
beaucoup ce cas particulier
johan duhaime et la responsable des
technologies de l'information chez hydro
québec
il y avait beaucoup de spéculation qui
disait est ce qu'ils sont entrés de de
tester sur les paris pour une une cyber
attaque pour affecter l'ensemble de
l'amérique du nord pour les tous qu'il
alimentation électrique
[Musique]
en 2003 une série de pannes en cascade
frappe de plein fouet le centre du
canada et des états unis les deux pays
saisissent alors toute l'ampleur des
risques qui viennent avec
l'interconnexion des réseaux électriques
c'est une défaillance dans le système
électrique de l'ohio qui est à l'origine
de la cascade de pannes millions
personnes affectées en ontario 50
millions en tout en amérique du nord la
crise de 2003 résultait d'une série de
défaillances et de mauvaise prise de
décision de nouvelles normes
nord-américaines ont depuis été mis en
place mais les cyber-menaces pose de
nouveaux défis
tous les jours il ya des cyber attaques
on connaît pas toujours c'est quoi la
source de l'hygiène de ces groupes l'eau
l'ukraine la russie
même la colle et quand tu lisais les
mains ou qu'on voit que ya des adresses
ip les adresses qui proviennent de ces
pays là on a tendance à être plus
vigilants à l'époque de l'attak
connaître son réseau électrique
l'ukraine est en proie à de vives
tensions avec la russie mais ni les
auteurs ni leurs motivations n'ont
jamais été identifiés
on n'avait aucune espèce d'un disque de
preuves tangibles et qui permettra de
pointer qui que ce soit du doigt virus
informatique chevaux de troie rançon j
ciel la chasse aux cyber pirates est
incessante la bête semble souvent
insaisissable mais pas toujours tomber
sur un échantillon le logiciel
malveillant et bury dérober des mots de
passe et autres clés d'accès dans le but
de générer des millions de dollars
frauduleusement à l'aide de serveurs
infecté à l'insu de leurs propriétaires
à sa grande échelle il n'est pas
question ici des réseaux électriques
mais l'exemple des bury illustre le défi
de détecter les menaces cachées et de
stopper les malfaiteurs
il y a quelques mois marc étienne et son
équipe ont réussi à s'approcher pendant
quelques instants des auteurs début
brille grâce à eux n'a pas un pot de
miel qui leur avaient tendu
[Musique]
à l'époque ils sont pas assez totale de
4 heures c'est de comprendre sur quoi
t'attendre
avant de nous envoyer le petit message
lots et cette année paul les travaux de
17 ont aidé le avrillas et à faire
condamner un citoyen russe
quarante six mois de prison l'an dernier
avec ses complices derrière le logiciel
et bury il utilisait entre autres des
pourriels avec des liens cliquables
infectés ces courriels piégés sont parmi
les trucs les plus utilisés par les
pirates découvrir c'est vraiment utilisé
parce que ça marche
ni les mains et je pense qu'il est plus
fragile d'un si le comportement humain
mais à des gens qui s'y font prendre
oui et déjà qui se complaît hydro québec
doit composer avec des centaines
d'incidents chaque année de la clé usb à
risque aux tentatives d'hameçonnage les
événements sic exemple les tentatives
d'intrusion par des courriels mail
veille sur salat livre régulièrement les
dernières années on avait beaucoup le
comportement humain et l'éducation
quand on a vu que le groupe dragonfly
s'est introduit dans le secteur de
l'énergie
ça nous a préoccupé arrivée ils
utilisaient le harponnage le harponnage
à l'aide de courriels infecté ciblée est
l'une des méthodes privilégiée par un
autre groupe de cyber pirates à blé
dragonfly l'entreprise semtech le
traquent depuis 2013
ce logiciel malveillant a maintenant
réussi à s'introduire jusque dans les
ordinateurs de compagnies d'électricité
aux états unis il était parvenu à
prendre des captures d'écran des
systèmes lynnsha pouvait voir comment
fermer ouvrir une valve se sont placés
en position pour faire du sabotage
aucun sabotage n'a encore été rapporté
jusqu'ici mais les autorités américaines
confirment avoir identifié des victimes
de cyber intrusion dans le secteur de
l'énergie électrique mais aussi du
nucléaire de l'eau de l'aviation et
d'autres secteurs manufacturiers
critique il ya aucune raison de croire
que ce groupe disparaîtra ils ont des
objectifs à long terme
ils vont sûrement revenir
sept ans plus tôt on l'avait découvert
la présence de stocks snet premier virus
conçu pour attaquer une cible
industrielle dans ce cas-ci des
installations nucléaires en iran
un virus informatique si complexe que
des experts le décrivent comme une
véritable cyber armes développées par un
autre pays chatel courant manhattan et
c'est le chaos
il pourrait y avoir des morts à
washington jim wright siège au comité du
renseignement de la chambre des
représentants
c'est ce même comité qui s'est penché
sur l'ingérence alléguée de la russie
dans les élections américaines
aux etats unis la cybersécurité est
devenue un enjeu crucial d'un match de
haut niveau
personne n'est vraiment à ses protégés
on l'a vu au sein de notre propre
gouvernement
on a vu des intrusions dans les réseaux
relié à notre sécurité nationale
c'est une très grande menace à notre
gouvernement
jim prime est aussi à la tête d'une
coalition de représentants démocrates
qui réclament que la maison blanche
investissent davantage aux cyber
sécurité le gouvernement doit s'assurer
de protéger nos réseaux contre des
ennemis qui voudraient y pénétrer c'est
rené six universitaires dans un sous-sol
à saint pétersbourg ils peuvent causer
beaucoup de dommages à une démocratie
après la pause on vous amène au centre
opérationnel de cybersécurité du rouble
en sécurité
[Musique]
il ya différents marchés qui existait
des marques comme apple qui ont toutes
sortes de choses avant c'est un peu
comme des pib du dark web le magazine
alexis dos région qu'à nous fait visiter
le dark web
ce web caché qui assure l'anonymat aux
criminels qui vendent des cartes de
crédit ou des renseignements d'identité
volées ou encore des programmes
malveillants et certains logiciels
malveillants qui peuvent être revendus à
différents acteurs et n'importe qui peut
s'approprier ces le chêne malveillants
et l'utiliser à ses propres fins on voit
ici
renson logiciel le plus vendu environ 10
des bleus économique
il existe des couches plus profondes
encore des forums accessible sur
invitation seulement qui offrent des
produits encore plus performant et plus
coûteux et c'est là qu'on retrouve et
les chaînes mais bien les plus
spécialisés qui risque de mieux marcher
pour attaquer des cibles comme des cd
france ou de critique par exemple pour
chaque cyber pirates arrêtés
d'innombrables logiciels malveillants
continueront malgré tout à trouver
preneur sur le marché noir et fixent
touchant ce très rapidement nous sommes
à arlington en virginie
tout près de washington au département
du rhône l'ain de sécurité les
responsables de la sécurité intérieure
aux états unis et voici la cheffe de la
cyber sécurité
on est dans notre centre de surveillance
des cyber incident qui touche nos
agences nationales
nous travaillons avec diverses
industries pour restaurer les
communications en cas de désastre des
lumières au plafond signale notre
présence dans la salle aucune
information confidentielle ne doit
apparaître sur les écrans durant notre
passage
si on assiste à une croissance
exponentielle du nombre d'appareils et
d'organisations dont les réseaux sont
connectés à internet
ça crée beaucoup de vulnérabilité que
les malfaiteurs cherche à exploiter
depuis les événements en ukraine les
autorités américaines constate une nette
augmentation des tentatives d'intrusion
dans les systèmes industriels grossistes
us à 2
ces systèmes de contrôle géré par
ordinateur des réseaux électriques par
exemple
depuis deux ans on a vu nos adversaires
s'intéresser davantage à des façons de
nuire à ses systèmes techniques se sont
améliorées aux etats-unis le secteur de
l'électricité est composé d'une
multitude de compagnies privées et de
plus de 2000 services publics gros et
petit comme ici à manassas en virginie
population 43 mille habitants comment un
logiciel malveillant pourrait l'affecter
au système le chanteur ne peuvent couper
l'électricité à toutes les villes même à
l'usiné de filtration d'eau partout le
soleil
[Applaudissements]
gilbert est conscient des dommages que
des pirates pourrait causer en accédant
aux commandes à distance de la salle
pourrait contrôler ce qu'on voit
derrière nous et causé des dizaines de
millions $ en dommages on a toute une
série de pare-feu et de contrôle d'accès
il ya dix ans notre réseau informatique
était complètement ouvert sans aucune
protection
au fil des ans on a mis en place
plusieurs mesures de sécurité en tant
que gestionnaire des systèmes
électroniques
randy winn surveille quotidiennement les
nombreuses tentatives de connexion au
réseau de la ville
mais peu d'entre elles sont très
préoccupantes à ses yeux ça provient de
la chine la corée du nord la corée du
sud plusieurs pays
la majeure partie en fait vient des
états unis
devant les menaces plusieurs entreprises
acceptent de confier certaines données
internes à roullens de sécurité
certaines compagnies énergétiques nous
demande parfois de travailler avec elle
sur des logiciels malveillants qu'elles
ont repéré fera souhaiterait encore plus
de collaboration du genre mais cet élan
et parfois freiné par la méfiance de
certains tous ne sont pas prêts à tout
partager avec l' agence fédérale
ça dépend vraiment du genre d'avancé
maintenant qu'elle cherche
je n'ai pas de problème alors dire ce
qu'on fait s'il vient de chercher des
détails sont d ores internet précise ou
des choses comme ça je ne crois pas que
ce soit nécessaire
pourquoi je leur donnerai ce genre
d'information même si manas à ce produit
de l'électricité
la majeure partie de sa consommation
provient d'un gros fournisseurs privés
selon les autorités américaines
des cyber-pirates se positionnerait
d'abord dans de petits réseaux
informatiques pour éventuellement
atteindre des cibles plus importante
là bas les world cran personne ne va
passer par chez nous pour s'attaquer à
une plus grosse cible qui a pas de façon
de faire une certaine confiance règne
aussi chez hydro québec
un des gros joueurs de l'industrie avec
ses interconnexions aux états unis la
société d'état assure une vigie de sa
cyber sécurité 24 heures par jour
hydro québec dispose aussi de son propre
réseau de télécommunications pour ses
infrastructures électriques nous donne
est qu'on contrôle l'ensemble notre
environnement notre réseau de
télécommunication dessert nous mêmes
donc les dix d'inclusion sont moins
d'options fut presque nil est ce que
vous croyez que c'est possible chez vous
vous ayez peut-être ce genre de choses
la dame aux stands et je ne crois pas si
jamais on découvre les quelque chose de
ce genre l'eau je suis confiant qu'on
sait capable de le confiner il limiter
les impacts pour étude sa vie pour se
propager
ils disent aux consuls je n'ai jamais vu
d'organisation grosses ou petites dont
les réseaux sont complètement isolés
dans des systèmes erp métier il ya
toujours quelque part un risque de
correction
est-ce que les risques étaient jay z ou
non est ce que je pense que nous tous
les os et bien conçu conte et les
protections en place qu on est vigilant
là dessus
oui
[Musique]
depuis que la dernière campagne
présidentielle a été la cible de cyber
pirates
les etats unis considèrent désormais
leur système électoral comme étant une
infrastructure critique au même titre
que les secteurs de l'énergie ou des
communications l'omniprésence de tous
ces écrans des technologies et
d'internet en fait des cibles
potentielles d' attaques et menaces
évoluent et le problème ne disparaîtra
pas j'aime rhymes crois qu'il faut
rester alerte face aux dangers des
cyberattaques incluant celles contre les
processus démocratiques aux états unis
comme ailleurs c'est certain qu'il y
aura d'autres cyberattaques
il faut en être conscient ici préparer
et le canada est aussi à risque
[Musique]
au canada
l'urgence de la cyber sécurité se fait
aussi sentir
le gouvernement fédéral vient d'annoncer
une série de nouvelles mesures dans son
dernier budget dont la création d'un
centre canadien pour la cybersécurité
tant processus
ottawa le ministère de la sécurité
publique a refusé notre demande
d'entrevue pour une entrevue du
ministère il faudra attendre le
dévoilement de sa nouvelle stratégie de
cybersécurité promise pour bientôt
alors est ce que c'est le jeu du chat et
de la souris
on essaie toujours de garder une
longueur d'avancé
il y à des attaques qui ont clairement
affecté le monde entier il y a deux
semaines le gouvernement américain a
annoncé de nouvelles sanctions contre la
russie washington reproche notamment au
gouvernement russe d'avoir joué un rôle
dans les cyber attaques contre le
secteur de l'énergie aux états unis les
américains pointent en direction d'un
groupe de pirates appelé dragonfly les
attaques un projet laisse simple est
qu'il faut qu'ils les capacités de
défense évolué autant sinon plus
rapidement que les attaquants sent bon
rappelle aux autorités qu'elles doivent
mettre le paquet pour défendre les
infractions sur le critique
[Musique]
gino avec tout ce qui se dit sur la
russie aux etats unis comment elle se
défend justement la russie à moscou
considère que ces accusations sont sans
fondement et dit que la russie prépare
ses propres mesures de représailles
en tout cas visiblement on n'a pas fini
d'en voir de six de ces cyber attaques
certainement pas et la semaine dernière
devant un comité parlementaire à ottawa
des dirigeants du centre canadien de la
sécurité des télécommunications ont
révélé qu'ils bloquent en moyenne chaque
jour plus d'un milliard de tentation 1
milliard de tentatives de cyber
intrusion malicieuse dans des systèmes
gouvernementaux au pays
toujours ses audiences et aussi des
questions d'infrastructures critiques
comme des réseaux électriques
hélas ce qui va être intéressant de voir
c'est ce qui aura dans cette nouvelle
stratégie nationale de cybersécurité qui
doit être dévoilé prochainement nous du
temps parce que ça aussi ça va soulever
tout sur des questions qu'on ne devra
poser gouvernement fédéral
évidemment c'est inquiétant ça va
certainement devenir une priorité dans
le domaine de la sécurité nationale dans
les prochains mois je vous remercie
beaucoup jugnauth votre enquête
au nom de toute l'équipe et on espère
que vous avez apprécié les reportages de
ce soir et on vous donne rendez vous la
semaine prochaine pour une autre enquête
[Musique]